[Music]
hi and welcome to episode number 56 of
the weekly Google cloud platform podcast
I am Francis camper and I'm here with my
colleague mark Mandel hey Mark how doing
I'm all right I'm a little sad it's the
it's the last episode of the year I'm
also super sad I'm actually kind of
looking forward to a little bit of a
break but yeah it's gonna be clear be
sad not to not to get to talk to you for
like three weeks yeah it's gonna be
really sad I'm gonna miss you I'm gonna
miss you I'm gonna miss everyone yep
this can be sad yeah and we we know when
we're coming back already so just so you
know yeah we will be back oh yeah
January 18th I believe is the day we've
a creative fun generating which is also
Wednesday in the meanwhile you can
listen to previous episodes if you want
to but today we do have an episode
today's our last episode and we decided
to make it a little bit special so we
call the episode a year in review and
that's pretty much we're going to do
yeah we're going to talk through all the
kind of things we talked about pick out
some of our favorite episodes and our
favorite cool things of the week and
yeah favorite hunters like what happened
in 2016 that is worth mentioning today
and actually I thought you said lunches
and not launches that we can also talk
about that yeah I've had some really
good lunches yeah yeah we have very good
foot at the Google office yeah but
before that we have the cool thing of
the week the last cool thing of the week
okay things the cool things I got to
like this actually the last there's
three the the three oh my god okay so
there's three of them that's why you add
blank lines in the show notes so you can
actually follow but yeah so there's
three of them and they're the three last
ones of the year so I worth I hope
they're worth it the first one is I'm
gonna let you talk about it because I
know you're very excited about it I am I
am so um I think this is pretty exciting
everyone knows I am well into games we
have partnered with a company called
improbable basically you can think of
that as a like a massively multiplayer
online game as a service so if you're
looking to build a massively multiplayer
game online or a large-scale simulation
or virtual world any sort of games in
that sort of aspect we've partnered with
them
and such that they have a program as
well for people to use their platform
for a heavily subsidized amount which is
super super cool so they run on us and
we provide that power of them and they
provide that power to you it's super
super cool the company name is
improbable they have a product name
spatial OS and the partnership literally
just got announced right now yep which
is pretty awesome it looks really cool
the older images I'm seeing in the
videos they look like something I would
play so very excited about seeing all
the new games and new companies that are
going to be joining this effort and
making new cool things on the Google
cloud platform yeah and then as well as
that we have the new google cloud client
libraries for four key services which I
thought were pretty cool it looks like
we've basically been building these
client libraries as the libraries that
people can use for all the languages we
support for all the services that we
have now Google cloud and there's you
said there's four of them so there is
bigquery google cloud datastore
stackdriver logging and Google Cloud
storage and they are available for seven
languages so I'm gonna start with go
obviously obviously and I'll left Java
for the end now so we have go Java C
sharp know Jas PHP Python and Ruby yeah
and I think what's really cool about
these two is it is each each library is
very idiomatic to the language yeah so
if you're using these libraries it's not
like oh this is obviously a go thing who
is written by a Java programmer not
known as that it's very much idiomatic
to language so that you you know that
when you go to use the client it's
exactly the same as you would use any
other SDK within your ecosystem yeah all
my side I know that the go team has been
heavily involved with with these efforts
for the Go the go libraries so they look
really good I am for excited about it
excellent and finally pretty exciting at
KU Benet's 1.5 literally just released
is it really like what is going on at
the end of the year so much stuff is
happening I guess that they seen this
there's a production freeze and we
cannot public and I put things in
production instead we just do open
source stuff I don't know I don't know
it's so much cool stuff yeah yeah so
creepy needs 1.5 a huge number of major
themes around staple sets or pet sets
and proof Federation support
more simplified cluster deployment which
is great it's pretty awesome yeah I feel
like this kind of a tradition that we've
always done and episode every single
time there's a new version of criminales
and maybe next year we should start with
that absolutely we should yeah we should
definitely have someone to talk about
that cool so I guess it's time to go
with the main content and the plan is
we're going to start talking about the
twenty sixteen episodes and we're going
to be talking about the most downloaded
episodes and then our our personal
favorite episodes which are not the same
and then at the end we'll be talking
about our favorite cool things of the
week which is kind of a vague term to
say all the cool things that happen so
it will be more like themes what
happened like cool I'm gonna say
announcements guess apparently i
mispronounced launches that's all right
I have an accent too like I quote
unquote mispronounce things all the time
depending on where you come from ya know
I think this is really cool i think it's
a it's is um something that we can kind
of go back and look at what happened at
Google cloud platform over 2016 and i'm
kinda crazy amount of thing as a crazy
amount of things and it really is kind
of a year in review of google cloud
platform yeah and what it is and what's
happened in the last year i mean we're
not even better touch on everything but
sort of some of our highlights which i
think is super exciting and really kind
of you know it gives us a little history
of what happened in the past year yeah
it's kind of crazy to think about like
not that long ago there were things like
gke was not really a thing now and all
the signs like oh yeah it's only a
things only thing now it's absolutely
thing um so yeah you we were talking
about two thousand sixteen episodes are
starting their like we go back and we
look at the analytics and I propose we
go backwards from number five so number
all I like it to make it more exciting
make it more exciting him and we have
like a drum roll and like long pauses
like reality TV you'll add that on okay
so on number five we have episode 43
which is gr pc at Korres with Brandon
Phillips love this episode love this
episode love this tech super interesting
episode to see how customers using to
your pc and how they were able to get
like performance benefits out of it but
again like grp see like that's kind of
2016 yeah like that is really cool new
thing
people are very very excited about the
new tech so yeah really seeing that and
and cross cross industry I've seen
people using that I think it's a really
interesting piece of technology yeah
number four we have episode 37 gke 1.3
so true versions ago with Carter Morgan
yeah love this love this also because
Carter Morgan is now a developer
advocate he's part of developer advocacy
yes so he got he got on the podcast and
since then he could not stop talking
pretty much so I expect you people will
be seeing him around and about but any
podcast about like Cuba Nettie's or
container engine yeah DK and criminales
have been a pretty successful theme
there over the years yeah yeah yeah
absolutely anything about container
orchestration and management has been
has been huge number three it's another
open source open source project that it
is also incredibly successful tensorflow
if is a 31 tends to flow with Eli Bigsby
yeah another great episode tensorflow
makes my head hurt but it's super super
cool any like gets it to a huge degree I
mean like actually it's kind of
interesting you look at it like out of
the top 5 well actually technically four
and we'll go back to it but for them are
open source yep work inside inside
Google and given the history of open
source at Google and like how we used to
do things and how we do things now it's
pretty amazing to see the sort of
success we've had across the board yeah
it's definitely a good thing that we're
open sourcing as much technology as we
can very excitable button 2017 and see
what we're gonna be open yeah I think I
think we're we're on a good thing the
way we manage open-source products the
way we build communities the way that I
think we kind of release it and and so
let go of it in a lot of ways as well is
really huge it makes me very excited
about the future of open source of
Google yeah and my favorite piece of
like my favorite moment of tensorflow
episode was when he when Eli explain
what a tensor was and and I understood
it and it was like oh that is near yeah
yeah yeah I never thought like I thought
it was too hard it's like ma nights you
know everything comes back to Haskell
yeah so on number two we have number 44
Cloud endpoints with dancer early and
separate braheem
today and I'm very very happy with this
episode being so successful because I've
been talking lately a lot about Cloud
endpoints I'm working on a bunch of
videos and you know like we're gonna be
launching it is going to be [ __ ] GA
something so when it's a lot of really
cool things coming on a flattened point
it's interesting I I personally because
I don't sit in that microservices space
so much didn't see this one coming it
was a bit of a surprise for me yeah but
II button crazy doing really well and I
suppose that makes sense right like
generally a lot of people at building a
few guys like you can't really get away
from that in some way shape or form so
yeah if you can api's you actually if
you can microservices you have a cat
endpoint and you also have gke which is
used for Cloud endpoints and for micro
services and also grp see so out of the
54 that's fair yes it for I kind of told
what the number one is now we don't know
we don't know we don't know so uh so
yeah and it might also because then in
separate such people absolutely number
one number one nice that's a drumroll
low budget and yeah number one I'm gonna
let you say it's good I know I you so so
so number one summer number one has two
of my favorite things in it crew vanitas
obviously and John Wilkes yeah that was
a Buick 46 Borg and cabanas window with
John Wilkes I mean what can I say it's
John Wilkes so if you haven't listened
to this episode please go back to this
episode it is super super interesting
John talks us through how board works
internally at Google my favorite thing
is when he talks about building systems
for failure Yeah right expecting that
things are going to fail and with that
expectation building systems to make
sure they stay healthy and they stay up
and basically how communities came out
of those lessons learned from Borg it's
like John's one of my all-time favorite
people in tech and so like I was super
super happy and super privileged and
super honored to just sit in a room and
chat with him I gotta say he's awesome
yes yeah that I had so much fun
recording an episode and every single
time I listen to it again it's like that
was so much fun that was so good so
maybe we said we would interview him
again sometime so you know maybe 2017
yeah
no I've got I've already got a reminder
in the calendar ok ok so that was
according to the People's Choice yeah
what about our top choice yep so my
number three I picked out episode 52
recent one the google developer expert
summit that was fun that was fun I love
talking to our gdes they're amazing if
you don't know google developer expert
program its external people from the
community that we sort of highlight and
add to a program they get a lot of
benefits they get to come to us and talk
to us and cool stuff yeah you should
totally listen to that episode because
it's really awesome to see the community
outside of Google that really appreciate
the products we do and like to talk
about the products we do and you know if
there's one in your area you could talk
to them about it yep my favorite my
number 3 episode is actually something
we've talked about which is episode 43
grp see at current as with Brandon
Phillips I thought it was very
interesting because he was covering some
open source project that it was not
built by Google which is EDD and many of
the things that Korres does and how grp
see helped them move from GA Jason to gr
pc and why they did this and all the
different performance gains they had it
was a very interesting and also Brandon
Phillips is a very great communicator so
I thought I learned a lot and I think
there is a very good interesting very
good episode if you're interested in grp
see go check it has number 43 it's
actually cool because it's kind of full
circle like communities uses eps ed it's
ed nasa's you here at your pc yeah I'd
like one thing layer goes into another
which goes into another it's the magic
of open source yeah cool so my number
two I had to do something that at least
touched on games because games fun I
thought this is particularly cool one
episode 23 if anyone's bought games
through humble bundle we had one of
their teammates there Antioch spelled
who had come to speak to us about that
my particular love for this is that they
ran on App Engine and the big thing for
me was how they talked about how the
scale that they got like the immediate
spike of traffic that they received at
the at the site for people coming to buy
games wouldn't have been possible if
they had gone when just about any other
platform because of the way we can scale
at App Engine yeah
is it was a very fun episode and also
it's like the perfect use case for a
pension really because they have like a
huge pic of traffic yep the end the rest
is like not much so if you were running
on premise you goodnight like 10 times
more maybe I don't know how many more
machines uni I have just to handle that
given traffic and then what would you do
with those machines yep I don't know
play games or something so what's your
number to my number two is episode 38
and it's with one of my favorite people
Polynesian so we did this episode sack
reliability engineering with phone
innocent and it is very interesting
because he tells us about how Google
does s r e side reliability engineering
and it's an amazing thing like I talking
about SI ellos and essays and how you
don't want to have like one hundred
percent availability because it's a bad
idea unless you could reach that you're
actually missing out on the opportunity
of experimenting more and stuff like
that and it's something that I feel like
more people should know about it I was
reading the sre book the book is
fantastic by the way we got for free
because we Hannah we got our off-site
last week and we got every single one of
the people in the team got one and it
was an amazing book love it and and yeah
he's he put in such a nice way that I
love that episode I love that episode 2
if you're into ops or monitoring or any
of that kind of stuff definitely have a
listen it is so worth it and get them
definitely get the book the book is
fantastic yeah the book is really really
good so okay so I'm talk for your your
number one my number one so i will say i
would have said my number one organ crew
Bernie's with john wilkes but we've
already covered that so i'm going to i'm
gonna pick something else like
everything else I'm gonna go with the
episode we did with gcp next speakers oh
that was fun that was loads of fun so
our big premiere conference next we're
doing it again next year we sat down
with a bunch of speakers at the event
talk to them about what they were
talking about it next and some of them
were googler some of the more customers
if you're interested in going to next
next year it'd be well worth listening
to the episode so you can get a feel of
some of the stuff that probably will be
showing and the sort of quality that you
can come to expect it's pretty high
quality it was an amazing amazing
amazing event
yeah and actually feel like maybe we
should also mention then episode 21 we
did amazing demos from gcp next with
instrument that's true as well that was
a very good epic I was really close to
putting that a little list i have to
admit yeah they're kind of their kind of
continuation of each other so they're
both really good episodes about all the
things we talked about gcp night about
during cheese phoenix and all the
amazing demos they had yeah yeah I'm
really scratching the surface the event
like just like yeah isn't it any little
bit to give you an idea of what goes on
now you're from your number one I think
is a huge surprise yeah it is it is a
noche es with now I I love Justin but
now he was not a it was not much is it
was episode 25 go on the cloud with
andrew jen and chris bradford it was so
much fun I mean it was talked about
tweaking turkeys I come on yeah my
favorite one of my favorite things about
this episode little peek behind the
scenes we totally did it the last minute
and Andrew was sitting in the office he
was just happened to be in San Francisco
more like we should we should get enter
on the podcast and it was fantastic the
best buys I think it was one of the
first episodes or at some point I had to
stop was because we were laughing way to
me yeah so yeah like that was super fun
but also very interesting talking about
all the things about why go is cool and
why go works so well in the cloud and
huh what you can do with it and what
api's are available and stuff like that
so technically very interesting but also
so much fun so much fun definitely an
episode to listen to if you're
interested in go or you're thinking
about using go and you just want to
learn more about the ecosystem and
what's available in it or if you want to
know what one Catalan sounds when he's
speaking with three Australians yes yes
there is that as well yeah that was fun
excellent alright well I think that sort
of covers our list of episodes i mean we
could probably talk about episodes for
hours and hours on end but why don't we
talk about our favorite cool things of
the week as kind of a backdrop to all
the stuff that's happened inside Google
Cloud okay so the first one I'm gonna go
with is all the effort with that we've
done on education there's there's a
bunch of things we've done but the fact
that we open we open CP 100's which is
the Google cloud platform foundations
and you can go check it out on
the google account / training that is
awesome there's a bunch of course is
that really really good there's also you
can go pass exams if you want to but on
top of that if you're a student and you
want to use google cloud platform we
also know the Google cloud platform
education grants that is helping
students use our cloud for free and so
they can learn and they can experiment
and there's a lot of things that they
can do like if your statistics student
and you can get to play with things like
bigquery that is kind of an amazing
experience and then also some Udacity
courses and like one of my favorite ones
was the Cuban Hayes class on Udacity we
have our favorite people to our
teammates now we can say cast a
Hightower and Carter Morgan so yeah all
the effort and education and also
improving our dogs and all the effort
that we did on basically making our
cloud more friendly to beginners I think
it's an amazing amazing effort
absolutely now there's this huge huge
things happening in the education space
so that's pretty awesome yeah I
definitely am a huge fan of the
education grant specifically that gets
great we're getting into colleges or
awesome so one of my favorite things is
just looking at the number of things we
made generally available this year so
many things so many things I'm gonna
miss some I know I'm gonna miss some
they're just rattling some off light
cloud sequel BigTable cloud datastore
router CDN went went live I I am so I
identity and access management thank you
i tell you what i got on that for a
minute identity access management that
went live that's also a huge thing i'm
sure i'm missing so many other stuff but
just a huge list of things that when GA
this year truly shows i think the
investment that is going into google
cloud yeah and the amount of stuff that
people have available and the worst part
about this is being a developer advocate
you're supposed to know all of these
things ya know any decent graphics oh
yeah it is it is very good for our
customers not as much for our team yeah
lots of fun okay so i'm going to go with
this these are not really ordered in any
specific way but one of my favorite
things we talked about was spotify yeah
what if i'm moving to rural cloud
platform was awesome
the way our team was involved with them
so they could get all the infrastructure
together to make sure it was a
successful movement it was great and
also all the things that they publish
they wrote a bunch of blog posts and
there's one of the my favorite things
was polymer oh let me hear whatever he
tweeted something saying Google's
bigquery is the bomb I can start with
true the two billion things and compute
summarize down to 20k in less than one
minute and I think that the fact that
someone calls one of your products the
bomb yep surrounded by asterisks that is
pretty very good goal for two thousand
2017 get more the bombs well there's
that but have spotify in podcast oh yes
yes if you're listening to us uh and you
were for Spotify hello friend hello to
interview you yeah that was my I think
that that was a huge thing that happened
i'm so happy about it you're so happy
about it I think for me I'm gonna talk
about another thing which I love because
so often this is just interesting and
quirky and interesting the amount of
stuff that happened around like the big
data and machine learning stuff yeah
that's super cool we had a variety of
open data sets that got got released the
open images data set geospatial datasets
we released the cloud natural language
api the speech API but I vision API is
also there i guess i guess it was right
before but yeah so many api's and i love
the articles and the stuff that came out
of it the discussion of micro moments of
baseball can you can you hear the game
through data i thought was really
interesting and by far my favorite is
basically the Japanese cucumber farmer
who is using tensorflow to manage his
crops which is phenomenal it is 10
amazing i mean the fact that you had to
talk about cucumbers at the Google cloud
platform podcast is yeah like that I you
know like I think it just goes to show
the wide variety of things that are
possible like once you have the
capabilities at your fingertips oh yeah
so that's just it just blows my mind and
I guess it's time for my last one and I
guess it's not surprising because I've
been playing not as much as you but um
it is about Pokemon go and poke him ago
I think it was a great story um you know
it was it was an intense story with ya
yeah but a hype was real if we take into
account that container engine was
generally available we announced it in
august 60 our guests 26 in 2015 yeah and
a little bit later on in i think it was
in june something avec all of sudden
pokemon girl is released and it's
running on carbon at ease and not only
it's running on carbonated but it
actually grows too well on gk yeah it
grows to be the biggest cluster ever
it's like huge and not only that but on
top of that they're like happy about it
and from the experience we create a
disney team serie customer reliability
engineering which i think it's a great
thing to say Oh like sr is a cool yeah
but why don't you get access to them as
a client so yeah let's let's look at a
customer relevant in engineering which i
think is great there's a blog post about
it it was very good and and then also a
lots of people were running on JK i
think that we interviewed Tim Kelton
from the car test lab and I thought that
that was pretty amazing and they were
talking about how they were running
there their whole thing on Cooper
Nettie's and accessing big table which
is like how Googlers do it right yeah it
is very much experience it's like it's
like Google for everyone else yeah great
I'm very happy about the the whole thing
about gke growing so fast and people
getting so excited and pokemon girl like
basically exploded in popularity yep and
still been successful so Frank very very
happy yeah yeah no I totally totally
agree the the velocity of Cuban a decent
uke has not slowed down in the slightest
oh yeah which is amazingly and crazy and
basically at pokemon go served what like
everybody like just everybody it is
pretty amazing cool alright so my my
final one I just want to highlight it
because if something I helped create and
it made me feel very special and I love
what's going on there the Google cloud
platform community slack team yeah it's
like community there that has grown into
such a wonderful community I'm so I'm
genuinely proud of it because so often
sometimes I just sit back and I watch it
and i watch the people in the community
of the Google cloud platform groups just
interact with each other be nice to each
other
help each other out really just kind of
be there for each other which i think is
just a delightful thing yeah and I guess
we these are like we owe shot out to the
podcast channel yeah in the in the
community there they're amazing I I
think it's pretty cool to get so many
questions of the week and cool nuttin we
don't get that many cool things of the
week from them they should send them to
yeah we get definitely get questions of
the week we go through the wig and and
there they're like they helped us so
much yeah absolutely so like just a huge
fan if you're not in the slack channel
check it out everyone there is really
lovely and there's lots and lots of
people there looking to help other
people out with what they do and how
they're building stuff on Google cloud
platform it's super cool yeah and i
think it's it's a nice way to finish the
episode thanking the whole community and
yeah for being there and thanking all
our audience yeah thing like I think
that we get we got a crazy amount of
audience over this year to the point
that we decided not to take a break in
but we're definitely taking a break
guess we deserve it yeah absolutely no I
just want a second that everyone who's
listened to us we love you it's been
it's been a great year of growth for us
and we're super happy about the podcast
and we have huge things planned for the
upcoming year yep I will definitely say
though if you want to put in the
comments putting the podcast thing put
in reddit reach out to us on Twitter or
whatever tell us your favorite episodes
tell us your favorite cool things would
love to hear like what were your
favorite moments later on the podcast or
like cool things that happen to Google
Cloud we would love to hear that back
from you and if you want to send those
as audio we're always trying to be
trying to make that a thing where we get
from some of the audience talking to us
directly that'd be that'd be fun so I
don't know how you're gonna do that
maybe on Twitter or just post it on
soundcloud or whatever your soundcloud
you can put a file on dropbox or google
drive or anything just send us a link
we'll make it work we'll make it work
make it work so i guess that it is time
to say goodbye until generating yep
and would you like to share your plans
until until then I'll be around San
Francisco just you know having a nice
vacation and getting ready for the
craziness that is next year yes yes and
they said the magic working there next
yeah yeah so next next year there are
details on that live already so you can
go to the website you can buy tickets
right now also making plans personally
for the game developer conference here
in San Francisco I know you have a
variety of events as well oh yeah so
I'll be coming back actually by the time
we publish the next episode I'll be back
to Europe oh good yeah I'm going to
Europe for Christmas and then he'll be
back there for golab I thought I yo in
Italy then I go to force them in
Brussels at the beginning of every so
yeah and after that India for gopher con
and after that next fun sounds like fun
yes that's lots of light lots of fun all
right then front desk well thank you to
you for joining me for yet another week
thank you for joining me for a whole
year and I guess I won't speak to you
next week no yay alright then well then
I will see you next year see you all
next year
[Music]
you
[Music]